while 94 1 backstage right now wilds
flesh I'm sitting next to the man
himself he just tore that stage down
meek Milly what's up buddy how you
feeling man feel good to be back doing I
love it dope back in Tampa
yeah man yo how was that crowd receiving
you man they loved it brothers laugh you
know I got like an energy type set so
you know everybody was turned up crowd
participation you know and we in Temple
of Diana how do you decide which song -
I mean obviously you close it out with
the dreams in nightmares intro which is
still I mean it you can argue and say
that might be the greatest club song of
all time
yeah how do you decide which switched on
the clothes you wanna record you want to
start it off exciting and keep the
middle going and ended up exciting you
know I'm saying so people can leave with
that memory that it was a good show and
when you first come on like they take
your first perception and your last you
know I'm saying so I try to give them
some of my best
straight up eight I know you um well
first of all Kanye just drop some kicks
on his own but I know you've been
rocking with boomer for a bit oh we get
a signature Meek Puma shoot yeah we got
a UH signature meek pull more on the way
you know I mean I'm just working
touching it up and design it cuz I want
mine to be different and I wanted to
represent like Meek Mill so you know
this this is the Meek Mill a classic
right here yo I feel like man it's been
such a great 2015 for you so far yeah
how you feel man how what's your mind
state right now how's me feel my mind
state is dreams worth more than money
I'm coming real real soon we really
doing a bunch of promo I'm behind it
we're just giving the fans what they
want because they had to wait so long
yo I gotta give you some props on that
Raekwon freestyle you drop - yeah ice
cream I've been playing man we do a
Sunday night hip-hop show I've been
running that boy yeah yeah that's love
so that's just one of the joints I had
to touch the streets and give him
something man let him know Meek Mill
still spit yes come on did you did red
corner go space reach out after you have
to uh nard ain't no Home Instead oh jeez
I know they approve I stand for they
tight wrap so all oh Jesus really be
now as much as as dreams dreams of
nightmares was such a successful debut
album I still feel like there's so much
underrated [__] like traumatized is one
of my favorite Tony's story Tony's story
and traumatized to me are like some of
the best storytelling recent hip-hop
yeah where are you gonna take us with
this new album out in the new album man
I'm a touch they hard I'm gonna be
political I'm gonna give them the energy
we're gonna test the ladies and we're
gonna put it all in one cousin ain't
really no art is that right now that I
see that contested Street that could be
Larrick ooh that could touch the label I
mean the ladies get political and still
smash the club straight up I know I'm
Kevin gates was on the show as well I
feel like that's someone else who has a
really good relationship with the skrang
but he could touch the streets he got
touched the ladies and you know I make
good music straight-up
Meek Mill we're looking forward to a new
album which is coming soon yeah coming
very soon coming are you gonna are you
gonna pull one of these a 3-week out pro
bono you know weird Rick just announced
to get album yeah we're gonna do it our
own way we're gonna do it the Meek Mill
each one day we're just gonna wake up
and the big mobs gonna be nice yeah I
may let you know let you know I'm a dog
last question right now it's about wild
late
3:31 you can't get ready for Meek Mill
hey hey your tapes ready I'm about
nothing meet me I appreciate your time
brother your third man thanks for having
us out out the wild 94.1 we in the
building dreamchaser mm gee